good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
vanhorn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2023 2020 4
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since
2016 the foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series has focused on
the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and health Sciences our selected theme
for this year is focused on building
Partnerships for generative AI training
in biomedical and clinical research
where every Friday we enjoy
presentations from a wide range of
leading thinkers about the issues
promise and opportunities associated
with the emerging um notion of AI based
methods in
biomedicine indeed we'd like to remind
everybody that uh our 20123 2024
application cycle is open and we
strongly encourage Junior faculty
members working in areas such as the
development of generative AI methods
applied to biomedical research as well
as those Junior faculty actively
utilizing AI in their biomedical
teaching and research to consider
applying we find that this is a very
exciting and engaging program bringing
together AI platform developers and
University level Educators to better
understand the power the promise and
potential perils associated with
generative AI participants selected for
our biomedical data science Innovation
lab program will leverage these seminar
presentations as vital material for our
culminating inperson manuscript and
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the Bia beachfront Resort
located in Sunny San Diego California in
June of 2024 today I am delighted to
welcome our speaker Anna Bagon from
stansen Health uh she earned her PhD
here at the University of Virginia in
systems engineering in
2022 and her graduate work focused on
applying supervised machine learning
methods to novel challenges in Mobile
health and is currently a data scientist
at stansen Health um where she uses
large language models and traditional
supervised models to optimize patient
care she's previously worked at evolent
Health where she built supervised models
for medical risk prediction and outside
of her uh work as a data scientist she
enjoys exploring the Charlottesville uh
bookstore scene with her husband Tyler
and spending time with her assistant uh
Benny the cat and in continuing with our
2023 2024 biomedical data science
seminar series theme uh Anna's lecture
today is entitled large language models
for healthc care where are we now and
where are we headed this meteoric rise
of large language models like chat GPT
and others has kickstarted this whole
new era of computing wherein the answers
to even the most obscure questions seem
to be right at our fingertips and
advancements in llms have in particular
opened up an entire new world of
possibilities in the biomedical space
llms are now being used to answer
complicated medical questions about
patients electronic health records
enabling clinicians and researchers to
focus on identifying the best treatment
paths for patients um Etc and in her
lecture Anna is going to skim the
surface of how llms work and then
discuss how they can be applied to
biomedical and data science domains as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
so if you're watching us on YouTube
thank you so much for joining us also
our especially selected 2023 2024
biomedical data science in Innovation
lab participants and alumni are
encouraged to submit any questions they
have by the chat feature in their
YouTube sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of
Anna's lecture and with that welcome
Anna we are really looking forward to
your pre
presentation thank you Dr vorn very
happy to be here um so yes as as Dr vorn
said I will be presenting as much as I
know about llms which is still certainly
a very rapidly growing field within
Computing and at the intersection of
biomedical data science and many many
other fields so very exciting um this is
the outline for my talk we we should
take up most of the time but let's see
um I'll give you a brief introduction
about what we do at stance and health
and then I'll go into some of the basics
of llms both um from a high level and
low-level perspective you know kind of
showing you the meat and potatoes of
what's Behind These very exciting and
mysterious blackbox machines um and
algorithm
and we'll of course discuss what that
means for healthcare and some of the
strengths and limitations that we've
encountered in our work at stansen um
and then finally talk about the future
of llms in healthcare which should lead
to a productive discussion so with that
um briefly I will just let you know so
what we do at stanson is we use
technology to drive um Positive
Healthcare outcomes So for anybody who
has had to deal with the US Healthcare
system you would know that things called
prior authorization where often your
doctor writes a prescription for
something and your the company providing
Services um for your insurance needs to
just double check that everything looks
good um so to make sure that drugs don't
conflict that it's costeffective for
everybody things like that and so we do
what's called utilization management we
take that traditional model of putting
all that work on Nurse reviewers which
takes quite a long time and resources um
we try to automate that with AI and I
want to emphasize um we do that so that
we can actually Auto approve prior
authorizations much more quickly we
don't deny um you may have seen
different uh pieces of news lately that
talk about the pitfalls of what happens
when you just throw AI at this problem
but we're very very careful to craft a
fair outcome and we only do auto
approvals with AI so this is supposed to
be a much friendlier workflow for both
providers and um anybody else working in
that space and it's supposed to help
patients not have to wait as long for
decisions like that so we uh make
Approximately 80% real- time medical
necessity determinations meaning you get
an answer right then and there so love
love what we do at stance and it's a
very interesting space to work in
especially with the AI component with
that you may be asking okay I've heard
about llms what on Earth Earth are these
and why are they so important right now
so if you're like me you have seen just
example after example and you might be
wondering why are llamas important why
are alpakas suddenly important um what
on Earth has chat GPT done now suddenly
Google also has something and I'm sure
you have seen the hugging face icon
everywhere we're going to talk about
that at a fundamental level llms which
we call large language models are these
very big deep learning models that are
pre-trained on vast amounts of data and
you may say great what makes that
different from a normal machine learning
model it's that the scale of these is
kind of beyond comprehension in the
billions and billions of parameters and
these algorithms that drive these models
are so special because they can do tasks
like summarization translation and
prediction as well as content
generation so
this is a timeline of some of the
Innovation that has occurred even just
up to March of last year and so this is
already outdated as frequently happens
in this research space so you can see
chat GPT was certainly not the first
large language model to come onto the
scene but it was one of the most talked
about models and most popular and so you
can see this kicked off just the Spree
of innovation especially in industry but
also in research hubs like Google um so
you see Palm um was one of the models
that has been developed recently
something called fla T5 chinchilla which
was focused on efficiency and of course
recently more Innovations from open AI
with regard to chat GPT so just a ton
here under the hood so you may be
wondering okay how do these work so the
architecture of llms is these are what
we call Transformer models which are
neural networks that learn cont context
and meaning by tracking the
relationships in sequential data such as
words in a sentence and so you can see
this example here from a very um seminal
paper in the field called attention is
all you need and it shows the
relationships between words as an llm
sees them so you can see especially down
towards the bottom here not only can a
word relate to itself which for
mathematics people would just be
something like the identity property uh
you could see how word like my also
relate to things that the the first
person is talking about right so in my
opinion all of those words are strongly
connected to the word my and so this is
just an example of what it would look
like to an llm to map this out and this
type of model Transformer model can be
used to do seemingly simple things for a
human in a a very efficient way um it's
certainly not so simple for a machine
learning model and I'll show you what I
mean so imagine a scenario where you
want to predict the next word in a
sentence now this one's tricky I went to
the blank there are many different
things as that you could guess based on
this now as a human if I have context
let's say a friend is telling this to me
and I know that they were running
errands and they had told me about this
most likely I would say hm they probably
went to the store but for a machine
learning model like an llm this is a lot
trickier this has to be these different
components of this sentence have to be
represented by probabilities and what we
call weights so yes the different um
coefficients if you will attach to the
different pieces of information in that
sentence and so you can see here it's
this really complex structure that can
be summarized to an encoder and a
decoder where on the left here and the
encoder takes the sentence and it you
know it assigns the different weights
that it needs to actually represent it
mathematically and the decoder does
something called masked multi-head
attention now I'm certainly not an
expert in this but what I can say at a
high level is that attention goes back
to that slide I showed you before it's
the mechanism that allows the llm to
focus on these different relationships
and ultimately make an appropriate
prediction for the next
word now I'm sure all of you are
familiar with this example so I threw it
in here it's quite funny but on a
serious note you need to be able to
learn from examples as a machine
learning model the um neat thing about
llms is that they can actually learn off
the shelf so they can learn about new
tasks off the shelf with with no
examples whatsoever so I could take Jet
gbt and ask it to do something that it
may not have trained on like um predict
or let's say class ify the type of tree
that's out in my yard based on a picture
um it may not have trained on that exact
picture but it has general knowledge of
the world however you have to be careful
because it without examples giving the
llm a novel task may not work as well
which is illustrated by this I think a
lot of people do think that AI is in
this incredibly sophisticated state
where it can make predictions left and
right with no help and that's not
exactly true if I were to ask a large
language model to actually classify or
let me say a Transformer model to
classify a picture of a cat it could
very well call it a dog if it hasn't had
enough training and experience of real
world images but if I give it an example
like several images of cats or just one
in this case which we call onot learning
it may actually do better at classifying
and discriminating between different
pictures so perhaps a more um relevant
example to what y'all do in biomedical
research and what we do at stanson with
medical charts is learning from with
with mathematical reasoning and so we
don't necessarily focus on this but you
can see an example of what happens when
you walk the LM through the logic
required to solve a math problem so this
is what we call Chain of Thought
prompting so on the left you can see you
give it this math problem as an example
and you just give it the answer with no
explanation unsurprisingly it doesn't do
too well at explaining its work like we
are all required to do with a math
problem and it gives the wrong answer
and we don't know why but on the right
here if you see how we walk the llm
through different steps of the process
to get to the correct answer it then can
do the same thing in its output so this
is a variant of one shot learning called
Chain of Thought prompting and it's very
very useful
um for things not just related to math
but also with interpreting text in
general and you can see the impact so
this is from a paper called large
language models or few shot Learners you
can see an example here of that compares
model size and also whether you're using
zero shot or one shot learning you can
see the larger the model size and the
more examples you give it even just with
a few examples the performance
significantly increases this is a really
interesting
comparison and if we move on to this
we'll see again this is only up to date
to March 2023 but this should blow you
away basically this shows if you look
all the way here on the left you can see
where gpt1 started out with it what is
considered a very small model nowadays
so this is 117 million parameters and
it's considered this tiny Speck in a sea
of huge models today and so you can see
how these compare Bert was another
foundational model in this space and
again it's this tiny spec and so I
encourage you um here's the link if
you're interested this graphic is really
cool just to kind of see how far we've
come with truly large large language
models now one thing you can do with
large language models is something
called Fine tun
so these models can be fine-tuned in the
sense that you can take it you know it's
been pre-trained on a very large amount
of data but then you can also sort of
retrain it you can train it further to
understand a novel task so one example
I'll give is what we do at stanson we
use llms to understand medical charts
and you can imagine a generalized model
like T5 fla T5 may not have trained
excit explicitly on medical knowledge
and certainly not exclusively and so we
need to certainly give we we need to
train over time so that the llm gets
good at learning well what kinds of
medical terminology words am I looking
for um why you know which words are
important and stand out for our
prediction task so um the way this is
done is you give it a set of labeled
examples much like you would in
traditional supervised learning um but
but in this case the models weights get
updated in order to make better
predictions now there's been several
examples of of innovation and
fine-tuning um this is where we get into
a little more math than than I would be
um good at explaining but like I said at
a an upper level so we have these two
things called Laura and Q Laura and this
is if you're interested at working on
some of these low-level problems so
Laura reduces computational cost by
actually freezing the parameters of the
model and then using decomposition
matrices to cut down on the sheer number
of trainable parameters needed now like
I said I I would not be good at
explaining how this works in detail but
what the takeaway from this is is that
it saves time and money and compute so
it's very um useful especially if you're
working with some of those larger models
now Cura is a variant of this that
actually came out last year that gets
down to the bit level of how we
represent numbers so if you recall for
those of you who took Computing courses
or who work in this space regularly you
have to represent numbers to a computer
with different bits and you have your
sign bit indicating if it's positive or
negative Etc this is an example of an
8bit binary number and so you can
imagine more bits more compute needed
more space more time Etc uh with
something like Q Laura you can reduce
how numbers are represented down to a
tiny four-bit space and still retain
accuracy and
performance now you can see this in
action by some of the experiments that
one of my colleagues did and um that I
have done in the past are different
medical tasks so in this case and these
are renamed just for the the sake of
privacy for the tasks we are working
with but at a general level we work with
medical charts and so for task two for
example the green color that would be
trying to get the llm to detect language
describing diabetes in a patient's
medical chart similarly task three
pertains to depression language and so
you can see when you just throw an llm
out of the box at one of these problems
if you compare it to a baseline which in
this case was XG boost the performance
may not be much better and may be
significantly worse because the LM has
no idea what it's doing but if you
fine-tune it suddenly you can see
performance compared to the Baseline is
the excitement it's it's better it's
what everybody's been talking about
about how exciting these models are and
so this is a great example of why you
might want to pay attention to things
like fine-tuning if you start working in
this space going to pause here for a
moment all right so if you're
if you're still watching and you've
stuck with me which I hope you are this
is the meat and potatoes of why you're
here so we've gotten this broad overview
of llms and what they do now I'm going
to describe the uses of llms in
healthcare from from a perspective of
somebody who's been working directly
with it it's a really exciting
time so one thing we might want to
understand better first though is what
is the difference between these
generalized llms and medical
llms um you can imagine these are
trained on different data sets so um and
and they're designed differently
fundamentally so a model like chat GPT
is supposed to have very broad knowledge
of the world so that it can answer a
variety of questions from many different
domains you can ask it about politics
science Health religion we've seen this
in all the funny examples that people
send each other saying look at what chat
GPT told me um this is just one example
and it can address both medical and
non-medical tasks as can many of these
generalized llms but as we talked about
it may not perform as well and so
medical llms are of particular interest
to this community because it's it's this
powerful variant that we would hope
would perform better on medical image
data sets on um things like exam
questions which we'll talk about later
and of course on patient charts and so
medical llms like Med Palm for example
or Med alpaca are designed to have
medical knowledge fundamentally and to
use that to drive decision making so
these models are pre-trained on
biomedical data sets so you may be
familiar with mimic Med QA these include
things like clinical notes lab values
images things that chat GPT most likely
did not focus on and as a result these
models in general are likely to perform
better on medical tasks such is
answering complex questions about a
patient's chart and so that's the first
example I'm going to give you we at
stanson use llms to extract info from
medical records this by the name is
called extractive question answering and
it helps us quickly get information
about a patient's medical history so for
those of you on the medical side instead
of more of the the technology side which
is probably a lot of this audience
you'll not noticed here this patient is
probably at risk of a few things and so
the first step to understanding this
patient might be to say well we've got
to check the patients A1C pertaining to
blood sugar and so we can ask that and
get a very straightforward answer this
is partially and so this is wrong this
is a typo on my part but it's
6.2 so this would be an an indication of
information being
clearly there in the record and easily
extract
you can imagine this is a lot simpler
than doing something like programming
out exactly how to extract number from
this part of chart and move to this data
frame Etc a lot less tedious and a lot
more user friendly to just ask in
natural language give me this
measurement that's one
example now the next step to that if you
will is to identify patient risks this
is a little more tricky because this is
called generative question answering
it's used where the information you're
looking for may not be explicitly stated
in the patient's medical record but we
need answers to help understand what
conditions the patient might have and so
the llm kind of has to learn through all
of its weight updates the encoder
decoder structure it has to learn how to
understand oh these numbers in in
together might mean the patient is at
risk of diabetes or pre-diabetes and
hypertension and so that's tricky you
certainly have to have a lot of examples
to get it to start to understand what
it's looking
for and I think the third so this is way
out of my domain but it's certainly a
cool cool idea for future work on our
end is interpreting medical images so
Med Palm has been kind of famous for
this and it's certainly not the only one
but you can see an example here of um
interpreting a patient's MRI at their
lungs and understanding if there's
something like a collapsed lung or
internal bleeding something like that um
and again forgive me I'm not a medical
expert but this shows how quickly you
could get answers in a setting like a
trauma ER for example where interpreting
images quickly can mean the difference
between the patient coding and not
coding it's very important
and so a lot of you may be asking okay
but what's the actual proven performance
on this I'll give you an example so this
one um I think this is the paper that
scared everybody because this is the one
that showed tools or models like Med
pomm can actually answer questions from
the US medical licensing exam with such
accuracy that it could pass the exam um
now nobody is saying this llm is a
Doctor by any means there that opens up
a whole can of worms but what this does
show is that it can answer these
questions with pretty high accuracy and
not only that but if you look at this
chart on the right this shows that often
times the llms answer can actually
demonstrate decent reading
comprehension good knowledge recall High
reasoning so things that
we would not expect from a machine
learning model and often times forgive
me to the Physicians who participated in
this but oftentimes the lm's responses
were preferable according to Independent
Raiders so I think all these examples
serve as just this this comprehensive
look at what llms can do in a rapidly
changing field
however we should talk about the
strengths and
limitations so obviously the strengths
are that llms are efficient at
synthesizing really complex multimodal
clinical data sources so as I showed you
medical charts lab values images things
that a doctor needs to be able to
synthesize quickly to make decisions for
a patient the llm can help speed this up
llms can also answer these complex
questions with almost no examples which
is really exciting these are also easy
to use in a clinical setting when set up
right so the doctor can use natural
language to actually request assistance
in interpreting medical results this
could be used by nurses during intake um
this has many many many
possibilities and it can also solve a
variety of tasks so all of these models
can solve a variety of tasks even if
they aren't medical specific
models however as with any great
pioneering technology there's going to
be some
limitations the first of these I love
giving this example is
hallucinations um which is essentially
the model is confidently wrong and this
can mean a number of things it might be
that the model makes up an answer
because it has no idea what to do it may
give a complete nonsense answer or it
may even conflict itself and so this um
I love this example because this
happened to me I was working with a data
set where I thought okay I'm going to
mix in these different types of
questions um some of them required yes
no answers and others required more
complex things like um a list of
conditions and so that's one of the
things I asked I said llm please list
all the conditions that patient Joe
Smith has been diagnosed with it says
yes that's all it said is yep didn't
know what to do because it had this
mixed training set and it hadn't
mastered the task
yet another one of the large limitations
of course is cost um you'll notice a lot
of the people and organizations that
have been able to make these models
bigger better and faster have a ton of
money behind them this is a little
disappointing because um not every
institution like UVA has the benefits of
something like Rana where we do have
access to gpus and sufficient compute a
lot of times you need Millions to
billions of dollars just to train and
maintain these models you also need
sufficient compute capacity not only to
do the initial fine tuning but also just
to continue running these models in
production long term and this is a big
barrier to entry for a lot of people and
a lot of
companies
in case you're curious you can actually
find estimates of how much these botels
took to to actually train the cost
estimate of palm Google's model which
has been adapted to variants like Med
Palm is estimated to have cost at least
9 million just to
pre-train I don't have that kind of
money and I don't know many people who
do and one big limitation now I
understand Dr Van Horn you said you all
have talked about bioethics and past
series for this lecture series and I
would encourage you if you're thinking
about working in this space to revisit
that so one of my colleagues actually
almost exclusively right now is working
to ensure that any models we build
especially llms avoid bias now bias can
mean a number of things in a machine
learning context what I'm talking about
here is more on the um social dynamics
definition
of bias so um whoops so basically a
model trained on bias data May
perpetuate stereotypes which can lead to
very real and negative implications for
patients things like
misdiagnosis um missed or misdiagnoses
so both of those worst patient outcomes
over time just a whole host of issues
and a lot a lot of times these are
biases focused on racial and socio
economic lines so there was a recent
nature digital medicine article that
actually showed llms May falsely claim
that black patients have a higher pain
tolerance than white patients which is
false and could be devastating if
implemented in a production setting so
again I would encourage you if you're
thinking about going into this please
please take time to think about what
your training set looks like and how
you're planning to apply this model in
an ethical way
so you may be asking what's next um and
I'm keeping an eye on time looks like I
might be a little Speedy today so we can
take a little bit of time on this slide
so the future of llms is it's hard to
ask and and get a straight answer but I
would say in healthc care these are the
things that I'm kind of anticipating in
the next year or two um I think we're
going to see continued just rapid
development of new Solutions especially
for patient care so I believe epic which
um manages many electronic health
records for a ton of the country believe
they're partnering with Microsoft to do
some kind of a trial run with using llms
um integrated into their patient charts
so very exciting um especially if it
speeds up workflow for clinicians and
for for clinical care providers in
general we're also going to see um this
probably a lot of adaptation of Open
Source llms to the medical domain this
is actually this happened already so um
alpaca if I recall forgive me but that
was a Stanford model that was adapted to
something called metal peka which was
focused much more on on the medical
domain and so people like open source
because not the community can contribute
to it and it's uh it lowers the barrier
to entry you aren't paying a large
corporation to actually use these models
so hoay open source um there's also
going to be of course on that note this
tug of war between open source and what
I would call payto playay llms I think
we're going to see a lot more tension
between independent research groups
working on these types of challenges
companies that are trying to monetize
things maybe on a smaller scale and then
very large companies that are already
doing this so that that will certainly
be interesting um and of course there's
going to be quite a lot of debate on how
these models and the uh what you know
ETL what we would call extract transform
load how you're getting the data from
one place to another securely because
you can't just upload a patient's
medical records to an open AI database
it's there are so many protections that
need to happen I anticipate on a federal
level this we will likely see guidelines
at some point in the future as to how
this should be governed at least I I
would hope
so and so
that's most of what I have but I will
say if you're curious about how you can
start working with llms these are just
some general resources these are very
very high level resources I don't know
um these aren't specific blog posts or
anything like that but I would encourage
you to look at them especially if you're
new to this so hugging face is basically
the hub for Transformer models
everywhere you can find pretty much
anything you want on there and it gives
great code examples and walkthroughs and
deep explanations of how these models
work and you don't have to be an
experience coder to use it you you might
want to be familiar with python um or or
get to that point but it's a very
userfriendly website um just got a lot
of documentation if you're a nerd
academic like me you will probably be
following ariv 247 because honestly this
is where most papers are coming out and
it seems like there's a new one every
day or every few days this is the best
place one of the best places you can
find new research with regard to llm
implementation efficiency anything in
that realm and then interestingly this
will show my age LinkedIn has been
really useful so I I often see when I do
go to LinkedIn I see independent
scientists and researchers and Company
Representatives all talking about their
benchmarking experiments that they've
done or recent papers that were released
so LinkedIn is a really good knowledge
dis domination hub for this and then
finally um one one course I found really
helpful when I started to work with this
is called generative AI with large
language models and I believe that's
taught by Andrew ing um I would have to
double check but it was really really
good quite short beginner friendly um
and it gave you just a a basic breakdown
of what these models do so I highly
encourage you to take a look at it and
that's not a a business plug that's just
a plug about how this helped me quite a
lot and so with that I am a bit Speedy
today so we we should have plenty of
time for Q&A and obviously Dr Van Horn
please uh pass around my email to
anybody who needs it and yeah I'm open
to any questions you have fantastic Anna
thank you so much for that I think you
know when you showed the the USMLE graph
I you know everybody kind of was
reminded that uh you know our
radiologist friends might be in a little
bit of trouble especially if the if the
llm the responses are preferred uh the
the role of radiologist might need to be
or might be changing U which is really
interesting but I I've keep seeing
things like that where large language
models are being asked to do the job of
that maybe somebody who's been you know
doing this kind of you know particular
task before and that there's a whole
career path about it and yet llms sort
of now being able to do that and perform
as well if not better in some instances
are there any other examples of where
you're seeing that kind of thing
especially as it relates to
healthcare yeah so I I will say you know
especially for anybody who's just
cringing in the audience and going oh my
gosh my job is being threatened I I will
say I have not encountered an example in
my job where we could only use these
models to make decisions except for that
auto approval piece I talked about but
that that is to the benefit of the
patient always it's just a quick
approval and off you go um I think think
for anything that's not an a easy
predictive problem if you will you're
still going to need human intervention
so so we still need Radiologists to help
interpret these images because these
models aren't always right um it's no
different than a team of doctors getting
a second opinion or third opinion from
each other for a complex medical case um
that being said so so yeah examples of
where this can be used in an automated
Way Auto appro approvals is one outside
of
healthcare chatbot responses and
customer service I've seen a lot of I'm
sure I've used one at some point where
it makes it easier so that customer
service Representatives don't have to go
back and forth on some of these simpler
cases like I have an Amazon return to do
um I I think that's the biggest one I
can think of right now so I could see
this I see these models directly
affecting Commerce right now in an
automated way Healthcare is still a
little bit far off from that I'm curious
uh maybe you can expound on this a
little bit as as you know there there's
the the nervousness about you know
turning over the decision making to the
machines um versus having these serve as
a tool or even a colleague you mentioned
like getting second and third opinions
as a as a tool or a colleague in some of
the decision- making processes in biom
medicine um and how those can kind of
help you can be little bit of a give and
take to kind of uh in inform clinical
decision making and research decision
making maybe you bound a little bit more
on on that relationship that we're seem
to be
building yes it um it's delicate right
and it can be fraught with concern over
whether AI is giving an accurate
representation of the patient so I think
there's so much we could talk about
there I I think one of the big things is
that yeah I think the I think clinical
care providers are learning that AI can
be useful and well I don't want to
insult anybody many already use AI in
their practices um some are more
hesitant for good reason I think what
we're probably what that relationship is
going to look like moving forward is
going to depend on the ethical
considerations and safeguards put in
place by model design ERS and uh Tech
evangelists if you will clinicians are
going to need to be confident that
people like me are building in extra
safeguards to say yes we're confident
that the model's answer that this
patient is at risk of diabetes is true
and that's actually a good example so it
is you know they talk about the the risk
of different types of Errors you can
make in machine learning so uh you say
something is true and it's false or you
say you PR something is false and it's
true it is much better in this case and
I think we could trust llm predictions
to say um this patient is at risk of X
because the worst thing that happens is
the doctor takes a second look at the
chart and says no but I've paid a little
extra attention to this patient and
maybe I catch something else um
alternatively if you trust predictions
that say no they're not at risk for
anything or this condition it it creates
them down because they're not perfect
machines and so I think ultimately
clinicians are still the authority here
and will need to be for quite a long
time the llm is a tool it's not a
clinician what are some of the
implications you mentioned in your
presentation about some of the the how
some of these things work and how they
perform when they're zero shot or one
shot or a few shots and um how when what
are some of the limitations about the
number of shots that one can take on
medical records because there's often
medical records are sort of they're just
sort of kind of a mess really sometimes
there there's lots of of poor structure
there's some sort like lots of free form
text um there's lots of Dr lingo and
shorthand for that may mean something to
them but may you know to even to a large
language model unless it's trained on it
it might not understand that are what
are some of the the limitations and
challenges that exist
there Yes actually you you brought up
some great examples that we we've
encountered firsthand so me think about
how to describe these um the first one
that will be most familiar to people
already working in this space is the
length of the context window and for for
those of us who who don't work 247 with
llms what that means in plain English is
how much stuff you can send to it before
it goes I have no idea what to do
because it's reached its limit um in
terms of size now with text in NLP we
break pieces of text up into tokens
right and so smaller models might say I
have a token limit of 512 tokens which
is very short the one one challenge or
consideration that you have to be
careful of is if you have this really
large medical chart and you want to
include things from the past in the
patient chart not just the notes from
today you're going to have to be very
selective with what you send in so some
of the text techniques we use is we have
to we use statistical calculations to
say okay which piece of text is the most
important which ones do we want to
include in what we send off for
prediction and we don't send all of it
um in the future or now that may
actually be changing because context
windows are getting so much larger then
the consideration becomes efficiency and
time right you can send a home medical
chart but it's going to take a long time
to process and Dr vanor as you pointed
out there's going to be this challenge
of messy text right nobody ever gets
clean text when they parse it from a
medical record yes and so um I know at
stanson we use techniques to tidy that
text up before we actually send it off
it's part of our pre-processing for many
things we do so um if you're thinking
about testing
out uh interpretation of clinical notes
or whatnot you're going to need a good
data processor for that and that's
likely going to be a human plus a
machine who knows what they're
doing what uh sort of I I I'm not even
sure if I know quite how to ask this but
you know at the moment you go to a
website like chat GPT or to your your
favorite large language
model you know website you input some
text into a text box and hit return and
it asks it to do something and then it
returns to you text or you know however
you're you're interacting with it but on
the other hand like you said with
certain um medical records you can't do
that there's identifying information in
there um you know sending it out into
the wild to be processed at Google or
whatever is probably fraught are there
any attempts
to uh say take a large language model
and burn it into hardware and then sell
the hardware to hospitals so that they
can use it within their firewalls and
all that stuff so that patient
protections are more assured does that
make sense it does yeah and you're close
it's um this this is a little outside of
my domain but as I this is more in the
privacy and security domain but as I
understand it yes the goal for Health
Care Systems is going to be um in the
current state of things they would
probably license a certain version so
uh UVA Health might say we want to
license uh fla T5 extra large or more
likely something like Med pom and so
they'll probably pay a subscription
service or do something like that I I
hope not but that's probably the way
we're headed um and in turn most likely
somebody from Google or an AI expert
will come in and get this this variant
of the model set up for them in a custom
way so that yes it lives with within the
the walls um the figurative security
walls of only that institution and you
aren't sending information out
willy-nilly if you will so I think that
will likely be something we see a lot of
in the future and what that opens up is
a lot of opportunities for new jobs
quite honestly not only for AI experts
but also for physician Consultants who
need to come in and say yes this is okay
no this isn't you know which which
components what is the minimum amount of
information about our patients that we
can run through this model even though
we've we've kind of kept it within our
wall Garden can you say anything about
uh query engineering does that is that
the right term basically you know there
are ways to ask these language language
models things there are multiple ways to
do it and there's some ways that are
better than others and that engineering
thing it's turning out to be a special
skill set um
amongst yeah again you talked about
different jobs and this is now something
that apparently one can do as a
potential career can you say a little
bit more about
that yes that should have been in my
slides actually but I I can certainly
speak to it um so prompt engineering or
query engineering I think both of those
are valid um it is yeah it's a rapidly
growing part of the field because it
turns out if you're an engineer that
also knows how to use natural language
appropriately people want to hire you
now now what that means is you're
probably so let's let's say you're
you're thinking oh I'm interested in
being a prompt engineer you have to it's
more of an art sometimes you have to
deeply know the data set you're working
with and the types of questions you want
to ask so uh the simple example is what
I talked about before do you want to ask
a yes no question um because actually
formulating llm outputs to match yes or
no a prediction can even be tricky but
do you do I want to ask a yes no
question do I want a list of conditions
um you also so you need to know
fundamentally and be confident in what
questions what the end goal is you also
need to know some Basics yeah just like
formatting like is it better to tell the
llm I'm going to ask you a question
here's the context context or is it
better to just straight up ask M give me
an answer to XYZ so again it's kind of
this art of playing with templates for
human speech and how we would ask a
machine and sometimes it real little
things can trip you up like you included
a weird character in your context and
suddenly it just doesn't like anything
those kinds of things are are tricks you
kind of pick up as you learn this what
are you had a Gra in there that I think
you got from uh I can't remember where
you found it um it was that life
architect.
aods graphic that shows all these
different large language models and that
relative size with respect to each other
and of course this is a the wave front
of these is moving like crazy so the
large language models that you know
today are so big in 18 months are going
to be considered cute by you know the
size that they're growing one question I
had about that though is that there's
multiple different models are there any
attempts to create kind of some meta
models that like go across the different
large language models so it's not just
one large language model one is drawing
from but they somehow are aware of each
other and can you know pick up where
another one might not be as as dense or
as Rich o okay that's really an
interesting idea and I okay forget I
mentioned it I'm gonna go open a
business yeah no I you know I haven't
seen that I would I think the challenge
right is that they would all have to be
within the same Suite of models or
company so okay so Google could do that
because they have different types of of
llms they've crafted for different
purposes um that would be harder to do
if you were trying to probably
impossible to do if you were trying to
make a Google model talk to a meta model
for example um I think what what is
becoming popular and this is where
Engineers still come in is let's say
you're not you don't want to be a prompt
engineer and you're not a clinician you
you like to program kind of like me um
you could be the person who assists in
what's called retrieval augmented
generation so um certain types of
complex queries particularly in math
will often need to Outsource part of the
question to a traditional program um so
it's hard to describe but basically you
could be the programmer writing
little Snippets of python code that the
llm will refer to when it's doing things
like complex math or struggling with the
context of what patient or what
clinician shorthand means in the context
of a medical record so um that is kind
of what I'm seeing now as the Innovation
piece for making llms talk to other
systems they aren't Standalone anymore
they're using other code alongside of
them yeah I could see that being very
powerful and that you could have these
very focused um uh llms that are very
domain specific you know you're going to
have one that's kind of the general one
right but then you have these others
which are much more of a deep dive into
whatever that particular topic area is
so it doesn't have to be in the larger
language model but elements of it could
be but then you'd have these hooks that
would go into the deeper one to pull out
more information of course from the
user's perspective they don't see any of
this it just you know happens but from a
technological and backend point of view
that might be an efficient way to do it
so that you're not having to carry
around extra language that you may not
use if you're not a radiologist for
example you're somebody else but
somebody who's a radiologist want to ask
a question the large language model
would know well I don't have that on
hand but I know where to go to find it
and they could draw from another model
um what one of the things which is kind
of interesting about our biomedical data
science Innovation lab and our seminar
series is we get to get opinion and and
input from people who are from not only
from Academia but from the government
and in your case from you know private
um Health Care organizations and I'm
kind of curious uh from your perspective
as having got your PhD just a couple of
years ago and you're out in the world
now what's your what what are some
comparisons and contrast that you're
seeing from the academic world and what
people are cons considering uh with
large language models in Academia versus
what are some of the things that are
being seen as important in organizations
like
yours yeah great question um so I can
tell you the big overlap is efficiency
matters efficiency and accuracy matter
in both academic research on llms and in
what we do
we we could get our hands on the largest
model ever that makes the best
predictions in the world but as my boss
reminded me it may not do what we needed
to do because the latency could be too
big or it could just take too long to
make a prediction um so I really
appreciate the studies that have come
out recently so I think chinchilla was
was the big one I remember but there's
so many showing the feasibility of llms
as they come out of the box the
importance of condensing some of the
weights and the bits and the bites and
things like that to to make it smaller
and more efficient I really appreciate
that kind of research coming out I um I
think the things that have been
important to us that I never would have
thought of in Academia are much
more they happen in our meetings with
our clinical product team um so we
consult with them so much so so let me
back up in Academia I had a great I had
lots of opportunities to interact with
clinicians in my last year of work and
it was wonderful but it was a different
type of work I was much more focused on
writing my thesis getting the experiment
executed Etc um but now I have to
actually be good at holding
conversations with clinical product and
to say are we doing this right did we
implement this correctly did I actually
get the right abbreviation for what what
this means um and so I think that's an
example of things that I wish Academia
would do more of is consult with
clinical experts in designing these
systems I think the big the big projects
and papers do a good job of that but
anybody who's getting into this research
you have to form those connections with
Medical Teams I'm glad to hear you say
that because our theme this year for our
um biomedical data science Innovation
lab is building the Partnerships for
generative AI training in in uh
biomedical and clinical research with
the theme being that you know the people
who are developing these tools and
developing these large language models
and cultivating them and you know
optimizing their use being able to have
Partnerships who are working you know at
you know patient facing or who are doing
research where these things are uh they
want to use them and then also how do we
train people to use these and this is I
guess the question I wanted to ask you
next is you know what are some things
that we need to think about as you know
you're a fairly recent PhD uh from just
a few years ago but like as somebody who
is learning about these what are some of
the things that people might need to
know about these um in order to use them
effectively and how that's not just the
end user but also the developers what do
they need to know about how people are
going to use these things and what do
they need to know in order to make it uh
so that it's uh transparent that biases
are removed as much as possible what do
they need to know as they're developing
these
things yeah I think it's hard to know
everything you need to know until you've
had the experience which you have to
have experience to get experience I know
that's the joke but but in all
seriousness I I think there's a couple
facets of this I think one you have to
get comfortable with coding um if you're
not and be confident that you can learn
that skill if you're new to it so I the
the people that I work with are from a
you know broad range of backgrounds
and some of my colleagues are huge
python gurus like and I'm I'm definitely
not um others of us are a little bit
more in the middle between human
centered Computing and pure Computing if
you will um so I think number one get
comfortable with programming and making
mistakes in your code and and learning
how to fix it um that's on a very
practical level um you know do trainings
do see if you can learn how to work with
tools like Amazon Sage maker where you
can get models up and running and test
them um so that's one thing and corsera
is great for that another thing you know
on the the other questions you asked
about what do we need to know for to be
prepared for avoiding bias and to making
sure that it it works
well get comfortable having
conversations with your team members
with
clinicians and I think you know staying
on top of the literature is really
important I I say that because I'm an
academic but don't be afraid to dig into
these enormous kind of overwhelming
papers that are coming out and try to
pick out the pieces that you
think are impactful in your line of work
um and get good at it you know if it if
you're if the important thing to you is
accuracy of the model try to build an
accurate model um you know I think it's
a lot of practice makes perfect and
keeping yeah on top of what's going on
in the world
do you have any parting thoughts for us
about large language models and you me
kind of you said where they're going to
go you know where will we be you know
again I was just think about this the
other day it was what like 18 months ago
we started to First hear about Chad GPT
and now it's like you know the
overwhelmed us in a degree you know what
do you see us in say another mons and
where where might we be in a couple of
years with
these
oh um I think there I mean I'm assuming
a lot of positive things will happen I'm
trying to be positive here I I see a lot
of companies really like like stanson
for example really eager to get these
out into their products because we know
it's going to positively impact so many
people so I anticipate I I mean I think
there's going to be a lot more
Healthcare startups popping up that try
to use these I think there's also going
to be a lot of counterbalance to that I
don't know at a federal level but just
in the community about how do we develop
safe practices for these um if I told
you where we'd be in a year my answer is
I don't know because this changes so so
quickly but I'm excited to find out I
think I am too Anna and I want to thank
you again for sharing your uh thoughts
with us uh some of the uh implications
of large language models how they're
being utilized in in healthcare this
fantastic talk and great conversation at
the at the end so thank you so much um
thank you everybody who uh is watching
us today and in the future and um
everyone have a wonderful weekend and
we'll see you next week thank you again
Anna